well you have to understand that one of
the things that ages the brain beside
oxidation is something we call
inflammation that's another of what i
call the Four Horsemen of aging and
antioxidants will protect the cells in
the brain just the way they'll protect
the cells and the rest of the body you
also to really protect the brain you
really need a lot of anti-inflammatories
in your body if you look at any disease
process whether it's Alzheimer's or
dementia or anything that affects the
heart or the bones or the muscles
there's always inflammation as a
component it flies beneath the radar
it's not the kind of inflammation that
you feel necessarily when you feel a
pain in your near you stub your toe and
everything gets all red and inflamed
it's a kind of subclinical inflammation
that's existing all the time and it
happens in the brain and you see that in
autopsies of Alzheimer's patients so the
more we can eat foods that have natural
anti-inflammatories and take nutrients
supplements that are powerful
anti-inflammatories and antioxidants the
more we protect the brain and of course
things that have nothing to do with food
like exercise because that gets oxygen
into the brain and it helps keep the
circulatory pat's running and going and
so this kind of lifestyle a lot of
activity and a lot of
anti-inflammatories and a lot of
antioxidants goes a long way to its
protecting the brain
well no food is all things to all people
I think of foods like friends like
you've got a friend that you'll go to a
basketball game with and he's great for
that but maybe you wouldn't talk to him
about your marriage and then you've got
these people you can really open up to
about your marriage but maybe you don't
talk to them about the australian open
when it's going on so foods provide
different things you know a food like
salmon wild salmon so powerful with end
with with anti-inflammatories like
omega-3s and protein but maybe not very
much in fiber for example which is
something else that you need so no food
gives us all of these things but the
antioxidants and the anti-inflammatories
tend to be really really heavy in the
fruit and vegetable kingdom that's one
of the reasons that one of the few
pieces of conventional nutrition wisdom
that I tend to agree with is to eat more
fruits and vegetables and you can do
that even if you're on a low carb diet
so the more vegetables things like
apples and onions are loaded with a very
powerful anti-inflammatory called
quercetin it's found in apples and it's
found in in onions and of course you can
get it in supplements as well so the
foods in the fruit and vegetable kingdom
high quality proteins and of course the
number one with a bullet the most
anti-inflammatory substance on earth
fish oil omega threes these things go a
tremendous way to its extending life